hey fans and maniacs this is a huge end
this is the day that I feel like he
needs more pomp and circumstance and I'm
going to go but we're playing Mortal
Kombat ax shouldn't with a joke who is
angry I'm about to [ __ ] kick his ass
flawless victory [ __ ] I don't know
neither do i we we we haven't played
this one yet obviously so one you're
gonna see some pretty low level play
from a lot of footsies I gotta go with
my boy Raiden oh I love the variations
yeah I don't know who to choose first
I'm gonna funder this build is hiding
some of the levels gonna do yeah right
right yeah yeah we get for the iPhone
good probably got to get my ass this is
friendly competition I must restore my
family that gift is safe all right okay
I linked hold aha so we should give some
time so look at them Oh lovely you know
you got multimers oh man all right mine
is we're doing what everybody else will
do down back what yeah I'm gonna pause
if I were if if I were yes and do it
again ready um
see Jeremy is really good off the
controller xbox oh you really gonna need
to do this to you for a second I'm gonna
be honest with you I'm about to do an
experiment okay let's go into x-ray son
of a [ __ ]
yes the x-rays do you - almost Ilana
snickering
Wow there's like dudes coming through
the portal
Oh Jerry he's angry I can't I can't do
my it's too or ever to redeploy here I
was living that earlier when their
method I was practicing dude yeah you
are practical index right it doesn't
work look at that [ __ ] back for day
sorry Elaine has no but we're gonna
switch controllers are you mister I
blame it on technical difficulties we
know difficulties that is nasty
but I love it to be fair Scorpius really
easy to use in this game yeah i are you
talking funny yeah select new spider and
you play with the broken man I just that
just means you have a win right here we
go
no no no I don't have a way I'm gonna
try somebody completely new yeah I never
played with Professor Kash Kade's
all right I'm going to be this
Oh
Oh Oh what the hell in that
I was trying to be nice I was like I'm
gonna get out of Detroit again so much
for being nice oh you've got me oh yes
right oh this is a poor ass play for
mine
I understand that that grab
oh by the handling it let's go
alright Cassie don't fail me now girl
long amid you too bad last minute you go
it's alright it's alright yeah what's
your Morgan
how she is like [ __ ] soul dude I love
Cassie's she blue ever died both she's
so cocky she's so perfect
alright you know I'm gonna be right
you're gonna be raining all right yeah
it's pretty good with raining and
raining is one of your mains at that's
that's gonna kick my is that one of my
minutes you know okay I'm a king now so
let's go with the water that seems real
good for me cuz ratings gonna
electrocute himself as he walks in I
wanna practice [ __ ] up right over the
phone
alright woo time to put Jeremy down
well you're chewing your mouse you blew
up my where have you been come great
Institute I love the fur Jovi what yeah
and adding cool album made me run for it
oh oh you're dominating me oh all the
fly across the screen that's gonna kill
me I don't know which direction this
dude I love raining so much so this
breaks my heart to see Jeremy do this to
me with my boy ray Oh [ __ ] x-ray oh
you've still got yourself
oh but I cannot
did he do it
Shazam all right I know it's looking
real bad
hey guys
all right now yeah
Jack dials I got my own timing out loud
we do I love and hope doubtful I love
raining i'ma go quan chi save us up all
right how is your her neck if you do I
didn't miss it
which gave the bonus to his telephone oh
yeah it was we woman to summon another
on back they gave him a name I forget
what the name was on the comeback so
many characters in this game that I want
to try to give you it ass
I'm soon oh man I'm scared of her Mac I
wonder if he's gonna dominate like he
dominated an MK that was the head of
what's-his-face we're different groups
oh yeah yeah no you're right
won't even let me pop it up there we go
what was I suppose what is he supposed
to do all right our Mac that's bottom of
the finish oh my god
domination oh these both sons of
oh my gosh
Oh
imagine leaving you wouldn't even let me
try it you know her Mac I don't know I
don't know American this one not the
same oh my god haha right boy oh connect
believe it yeah oh [ __ ]
I was gonna get away all right dude you
know yeah
once she is up close for a lot of his
mobile not really use with that but
we'll see
very controlling a lot of control on our
back
very true love you oh my god oh man that
was just domination I'm not going to
Jeremy that was [ __ ] awesome take a
moment yes okay I could not do anything
that was it was the last two moves list
move list here we go down up back okay
how we gonna wait wait we got we got a
professional over here how do you do our
max fatality if there's no down up back
if there's no button you whole block oh
not enough losses too scary
yeah Carmack's our max fatality
a little more challenging than some of
the easier ones do complete domination
that was a good round from your you're
gonna be a good or Mac I can tell ya I'm
gonna be the [ __ ] hot streak he's
pretty awesome yeah he's how if they
make an injustice to John Constantine
oh that should you like that yeah
alright here we go I'll need a trainer
Quan Chi cuz that [ __ ] was crazy I'm
gonna go coach oh uh Comic Con yeah I'm
gonna try K no K knows volcano all right
he heads up the what is it black dragon
lock dragon flu
rich but excels in martial arts Mel's
attached with black dragons karate so
it's a like Dana
he was going to take on a [ __ ] all right
here we go
oh you can combo that you spring it
Oh to the Kay node you'll immediately
just to get some pride back that's one
of my favorite one so far
it's the neck breaker oh let's Kano got
from old Shepherd damn hisses brutal
oh my soul oh [ __ ]
I can't get this move execute
oh she dared me to make little that was
awesome a tiny Z right it's not gonna be
enough oh sorry
they're either gonna hit me out of it
alright it's done go my god ha he just
kind of cradles in this thing oh that's
a good one that's brutal
that's very Kano just begun so there you
go guys that is the end of the Jeremy
John's angry Joe show combat of Mortal
Kombat X awesome I didn't know what else
to call it sounded fun though there's a
lot of fun he's a really cool guy and
I'm not gonna love this was the channel
where it's like my wins went to want to
see the other side of the story where he
actually kicked my there were a couple
where he kicked my balls in not gonna
lie all's fair and mortal and combat you
can check that out on his channel he
uploads it I'll put a link below or I'll
put an annotation here or something
check that out to see the other side of
the story and I like the outro that he
and I did so we're going to go back
there alright guys so that is the end of
Jeremy Jones versus angry Joe a few
desks a bit of destruction a bit of
mayhem but check this guy out this guy
does some great would you call them like
video game review yeah but there's video
game reviews but the like deep video
yeah
deep-dive video reviews and hopefully
eventually we'll do some rematches and
we'll give this back going but thank you
all oh if you like what you've seen here
you want to see more click right here to
see more lets punch it up save time I'll
have you guys so you can't see I doing
this three feet away and you watch me
get my head favorite link we're Usami
[ __ ] my ass
thank you very much thanks so much